ah 2002 when Marvel movies could just be
good movies that didn't have to set up a
string of universes and spin-offs and
sequels welcome to my series of
spider-man reviews I'm gonna be
reviewing every single spider-man film
including updated thoughts on the
amazing spider-man 1 & 2 leading up to
Civil War this year and it started off
we're gonna be talking about the
original spider-man film directed by Sam
Raimi came out in 2002 stars Tobey
Maguire Kirsten Dunst James Franco and
Willem Dafoe in the year 2001 I
personally did not have the Internet at
my house and so I didn't really know
about movie news or anything and I was
only about thirteen years old so I was
just sort of getting into the idea of
movies and discovering my passion for
film I had loved movies my whole life
but it wasn't really until my teenage
years that I really decided I wanted to
study them and learn more about
filmmaking and so when I was sitting in
a theater in 2001 and I saw a preview
for spider-man I lost my mind
I grew up loving this character I love
the comics I love the 90s television
show I even watched the 80s cartoon and
I watched the 60s cartoon it's a very
funny cartoon you re-watch a lot of
times spider-man spins his webs by going
like this he just makes a fist he
doesn't do the famous he like goes sorry
I mean I even watched the live-action
show that only ran for like one season
the music for that show was so 1970s I
love listening to it every once in a
while just for a laugh
my parents will tell you that I used to
crawl face-first down the stairs saying
hey look at me I'm spider-man spider-man
was a big thing for me and so going into
this movie in 2000 to my mind I was
there I was ready I was pumped it's one
of the first times that I can recall
actually going to a theater and having a
difficult time finding a seat it was
packed spider-man as some of you may
know was at the time the
highest-grossing weekend of all time I
think it made something like 114 million
dollars it was humongous it was the
first movie to ever gross 100 million
dollars in one weekend that's including
inflation so as an adult it was really
interesting to go back and rewatch the
film because my goal in rewatching it
was not just to look for the fun things
I remember when I was 14 years old and
my teenage years of loving this movie I
wanted to analyze the filmmaking and
really look at how Sam Raimi directed
this movie and I was really impressed
with what he did something I love about
this movie is that it really actually
does hold up fairly well yes it is
cheesy and yes at times it is a little
bit Power Ranger II especially with
Green Goblin suit but this is also based
off a comic book in which a man is
bitten by a radioactive spider and then
gets spider powers and gets to spin webs
and climb around the buildings so you
know not everything has to be dark and
gritty in fact that's what I love about
Sam Raimi's first spider-man film it is
gleefully fun it's one of the very few
delightful superhero films most
superhero films now are so obsessed with
being really dark and just oh
everything's sad I love me watching this
movie and experiencing a movie that was
just extremely happy and very fine with
being happy because if you go back and
read the initial 1960s comics I mean
they're cheesy as hell and Raimi is a
humongous comic book fan he has a
collection of thousands from what I
understand he has like over 25,000 comic
books so the guy knows the feel he knows
the world and I was something at
spider-man this first film really
accomplished well it's set up a world
that did feel mostly real and grounded
mainly because our characters are so
well fleshed out and the casting is
almost perfect as far as I'm concerned I
have not yet seen Civil War but Tobey
Maguire as Pete
Parker is definitely the best Peter
Parker we've had he really captures that
nerdiness you feel such sympathy for him
and Raimi did a really good job of
setting up the introduction to his
character as the camera pans through the
bus and we see Mary Jane we see Flash
Thompson we see the kid with the jelly
donut and then we get to pan to Peter
and everyone's laughing at him and no
one wants to support him except MJ even
the bus driver is laughing at him now
that is stretching a little bit because
you may not know before I started trying
to make a career out of film criticism I
worked on school buses with handicapped
kids and so I know for a fact the no bus
driver would ever be like haha stupid
nerd you're dumb yeah see you later kid
I'm gonna get fired later but this movie
just did such a great job of setting up
all of his characters in those opening
scenes and Willem Dafoe as the Green
Goblin slashed Norman Osborn is some of
the best casting I've ever seen I can't
really think of anyone else playing this
character he nailed it and what I loved
about his portrayal of Norman Osborn is
what went on behind the scenes if you
watch the making of documentary of
spider-man to read up on the production
of the film which I have he really
lobbied for this role Sam Raimi wasn't
gonna cast him initially but he kept
pestering him about it he wanted to be
the Green Goblin not just because he
knew would help him become more famous I
mean the guy was already in movies like
platoon he didn't need more fame he
wanted to play this character and you
can feel it in the role he's really
passionate about this source material he
even had the costume team remake the
entire costume so that he could perform
the majority of the stunt work himself
and he did do about 90 to 95 percent of
the stones in this movie and I gotta
respect him for that another thing I
love rewatching it is Danny Elfman score
still after two other people trying to
do the score James Horner rest in peace
and Hans Zimmer none of them were able
to equal what Danny Elfman did with this
movie his score is still very catchy and
it has this great sense of adventure and
epic weight to it all a reason that I
think Raimi was such a good choice for
director of this film is that he is
notoriously a very good in-camera
director because of his work on the Evil
Dead films the guide knows a low-budget
filmmaking the guy is used to making
films without a lot of CGI support and
not to downgrade CG I know CG has its
place in film this film is actually
remarkably in-camera quite often
something else
we did so well was set up conflict
between characters Harry Osborn played
very well by James Franco clearly has
some jealousy in regards to Peter and
Norman because Norman seems to respect
Peter more because he's smarter and he
can do things that Harry can't do very
well
now something this movie gets made fun
of a lot for is the whole Mary Jane and
Peter Parker crush thing and that it's a
little too cutesy look I can tell you
and this is a little bit of personal
information about me but I don't mind
sharing it when this movie came out I
had like the biggest crush on this girl
I knew I mean massive I'm telling you
when I saw this movie I was like that is
it if you've ever had a deep terrible
just horrible crush on somebody and you
were too nervous to explain how you felt
to that individual I understand that
feeling and I really think this movie
portrayed it very well actually and I
think you're some dunce did a great job
as Mary Jane Watson because the script
also fleshed her out really well she has
this abusive father her home life is
terrible she wants to be more serious in
her life and become an actress but she
also has this side of her that instantly
turns into the fun girl whenever she
sees Flash Thompson
after Peter and MJ have this really nice
conversation outside their house about
their dreams as soon as Flash Thompson
pulls up with his new car she turns on
that persona of I'm just the fun girl
instantaneously because she's used to
using that as a defense mechanism and I
know I'm looking super deep into
spider-man but really you should it's a
film made by people and they really
tried to flesh out these characters
really well and I was super excited
rewatching spider-man to actually
realize as an adult this film holds up
really well it has great character depth
really fun action scenes beautiful
direction Sam Raimi really honored the
character of spider-man you had also
remember when this movie came out
recently the only comic-book hit we had
had was x-men the Batman films had been
crushed by Joel Schumacher's last two
films blade was really good but it
wasn't like a massive success or
anything what they did with spider-man
was they said hey this can be a thing
let's really go forth with this and see
if we can make other characters and now
we're getting ant-man today it's nuts
again with the casting rosemary Harris
as Aunt May Cliff Robertson as Uncle Ben
these two were fantastic especially
Cliff Robertson his speech to Peter in
the car right before he dies it's
heartbreaking they nailed the with great
power comes great responsibility scene
and it didn't seem forced or attack
dawn it seemed absolutely necessary so
that later when Uncle Ben is killed that
whole revenge sequence with Peter trying
to chase down the shooter it's riveting
it's actually really suspenseful and
exciting still today I I'm not just
looking at this movie like oh this is
the thing I loved when I was a kid I
tried to shove all that away like I did
with Return of the Jedi when I rewatched
return the Jedi and really just look at
the movie in the way it's made and I'm
impressed
now again still on the casting JK
Simmons as J jonah Jameson is maybe like
top 5 casting choices of all time
this guy owned every second of film that
he is in no jobs freelance meat send you
a nice box of Christmas meat it's the
best I can do get out of here one of the
major negatives that I hear a lot from
spider-man's fans was that he wasn't
quippy enough in this movie he didn't
make enough jokes I actually think it's
a good balance because there are times
like in the fight with Randy Savage he
says that's a cute outfit if your
husband give it to oh but he's trying to
make JJ's shut up he says the quips are
there but they don't override the story
and I think that's just what I need
because you can get to the point where
you become an asshole and you're no
longer just being funny and you're just
being like a dick and I think they found
the right boundary at least for myself
maybe some fans had wanted a little bit
more of that I liked that Spiderman has
organic web shooters in this movie
because for one thing it makes sense if
he gets all the powers of a spider why
shouldn't he be able to spin webs and
the other thing is it's more realistic
because this kid is a dirt-poor high
schooler he doesn't have a job he has no
money there's no way that he could
actually create web shooters it's not
gonna happen and so I think that was the
wise choice and I love this scene where
he discovers his powers it looks real
like it is real it was like a a set
turned on its side it looks great still
to this day I when I was a kid I used to
crawl up the stairs dum-dum that being
said he definitely should be more
shocked by his body transformation when
he looks in the mirror and he's like oh
I've ripped all of a sudden yeah it's a
big change Aunt May yep okay whatever
and I love what he's first trying to
figure out how to spin his webs it's so
funny
go whip fly away whip Shazam another
thing that I hear a lot is that green
goblin just looks like a Power Ranger
you know I like the Power Rangers when I
was a kid do they have a place in
spider-man probably not I'll give you
that it is a little silly it is
definitely a silly looking suit but I
like it a lot better than dandy Han with
face herpes a lot more than that also
it's a complaint that just gets
regurgitated somebody sees it somewhere
and they go that's funny and then they
say it and then someone else says and it
becomes like a thing like that people
have in their head because someone else
said it and then they said oh yeah it's
Power Rangers suit that's the way the
internet works when this movie came out
the Internet wasn't huge social media
wasn't even around everyone loved this
movie and now the Internet's more
popular everyone talks about things and
our Power Rangers now it's a thing
that's my little unnecessary rant on the
Green Goblin Power Ranger comparison
also during the Unity Day Parade scene
which I like to call the Macy Gray scene
there's a kind of stupid part where
Green Goblin just has like a vaporizing
bomb that turns people into skeletons
I'm just I just want to know how that
thing works like do you do you make a
circle like this circumference these
people become skeletons it was obviously
just like we don't want to show green
goblin murder all these people so we'll
make them vaporize Raimi also did
something really cool with colors in
this movie like the dinner scene peter
is actually wearing the green Goblin's
colors Norman is wearing spider-man's
colors and Harry is wearing both of
their colors now that that really
matters it's just cool that they did
that it's like you know they weren't
just filming the scene they actually
thought about cool little things I could
throw in there for the fans and what
I've always loved about the finale of
this movie is how brutal it is
spider-man gets his ass kicked
he's bleeding from his face the Goblin
is tearing the out of him and
that's another reason I love that Raimi
directed this movie because he really
has this visceral sense to the way he
cuts films together and it looks very
realistic it's all in camera these are
people flying around getting smacked
into walls
obviously it's prop walls and everything
but it's not some CGI guy flying around
it looks real I'll never forget sitting
in the theater
with my mom in 2002 and her actually
closing her eyes and my mom watches a
lot of stuff we grew up watching the
x-files and gross creature gory bloody
stuff so just like you know she's not
like that kind of woman she was like oh
man and I just looked over and I was
like spider-man
yeah good job like I love that I love
the fact this movie wasn't just some
kitty fest it was at times not afraid to
get violent the issues that I have with
spider-man are largely just little tiny
gripes and nitpicks
certain things that could have been
fleshed out a little more maybe some
things that are rushed but I recognize
that as a film that is really trying to
tribute the comics of the 60s while also
kind of melding a little bit with the
ultimate spider-man comics they did a
really good job of doing that
I love Tobey Maguire as spider-man not
just because I grew up with it I
specifically watched this film looking
for flaws and while there are some of
them there I think they did an excellent
job especially considering the time
period this movie came out I'm gonna
give spider-man an a-minus thank you so
much as always for watching I greatly
appreciate it I am gonna be covering
spider-man 2 very soon you guys are the
best seriously thank you very much for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck man eyes